it is but please be as technical as
possible we we love the detail all right
okay uh I don't think you really quite
want that but I'll I'll go a certain
distance the last one was amazing I
don't know if you saw Billy got um over
half a million views the last one so
this isn't great
thanks to you thanks to you okay so I'll
crack straight on mlst is sponsored by
numerai are you a data scientist looking
to sharpen your skills against the best
Minds in the world numeri is a hedge
fund which is driven by models created
by data scientists like you they give
you immaculately squeaky clean stock
market data which you can train your
models on and if your models do well you
get paid which is nice see the link in
the description cheers so um last time I
was slated for making my introduction
too long so this time I'm going to keep
it brief not least of which because our
guest is perhaps the most recognizable
and brilliant scientist alive today Dr
Stephen Wolfram now being an experienced
podcaster I I have a bit of a sense when
I come across a scientist with a truly
phenomenal intellect and Stephen is this
person the only other um candidate for
me would be Yoshi Bach and by the way
I'd love to host a conversation with you
and Joshua at some point in the future I
did I did Ping him last night on Twitter
and he said he would be a game but
anyway
um I was listening to One of um Dr
wolfram's recent podcasts earlier today
and his insatiable hunger for knowledge
was abundantly clear he was recording
that show at the end of last year
talking about researching his new book
which we're going to talk about he was
pouring through ancient manuscripts
studying the etymology of words used to
ascertain exactly what those early
scientists were conceiving of several of
which remarkably were seeing the
universe as a kind of discrete particle
system decades or even hundreds of years
before it became accepted canonical
knowledge now today we're going to
discuss some of Dr wolfram's work on the
second law of Thermodynamics which is to
say the Dynamics of heat and frankly our
understanding of this phenomenon hasn't
really changed in over a hundred years
so um you know Dr Wolfram remarked in
his book that there's still something
deeply mysterious about the second law
it seems like it's going to be provably
true but one never quite seems to get
there we're still missing a little
something extra now Dr wolfram's quest
to understand the second law has been a
50-year story and now finally given his
many breakthroughs on his computational
physics project we can finally start to
you know pull the pieces together and
construct a proper framework to explain
why and to what extent the second law is
true now don't worry folks we are going
to get some AI questions in later but Dr
Wolfram it's an absolute honor to have
you on the show thank you so much and
can you sketch out some of the details
of of your new book
yeah well let's see talking about the
second law you know one of the things
that's fun and interesting is it turns
out probably some of the things that
we're learning about the second law are
actually relevant to Ai and llms see I
think one of the things that is an
emerging interest here is what we might
call llm science that is and we're going
to talk about the second law so so but
but let me just make a few comments to
begin with here that um uh you get an
llm you train it on billions of web
pages then you discover that it has all
kinds of behaviors and the question is
what can you generically say about those
behaviors it's a little bit like saying
you've got a bunch of you know trillions
of gas molecules in a room and they're
all bouncing around and what can you say
in the aggregate about their behavior
it's sort of a somewhat similar kind of
question but in the case of llms we're
we're things like you know how does zero
shot learning how does that work why
does that happen why does anything like
that happen why does it turn out to be
the case that if you take the
temperature you know the the uh if
you're using an alarm you you know the
temperature is kind of this parameter
that says to what extent how are you
going to which word are you actually
going to use out of the ranked list of
words of different probabilities
temperature zero means you always pick
the word that is the one that the llm
thinks is the most likely to come next
temperature one means you pick them
according to the probabilities that the
llm says they should occur with and and
so on and one of the things that one
observes is as you crank up the
temperature like for GPT for chat gbt I
think it's around 1.2 is the critical
temperature as you crank up the
temperature the llm goes from talking
sense to talking nonsense it's a kind of
a phase transition like the transition
from something like water to steam when
you when you uh you know go above 100
degrees Centigrade one doesn't
understand that transition yet that's an
example of a a kind of a place where
kind of the ideas and methodology of
something like statistical mechanics is
likely applicable to llms the thing
that's weird about llms is while all
those gas molecules bouncing around they
don't have particular labels they're not
you know the science of food they're not
the you know they don't have they're not
they don't have a meaning to us humans
what the things that we put into llms
are things that sort of we think of as
meaningful we think of as being kind of
the the knowledge of our civilization
and the fact that when you put all of
those together in this big kind of vat
you get certain kinds of emergent
behaviors is an interesting thing that's
kind of this this emerging area in a
sense of llm science which I think is
going to be quite important to
understand I mean the things we start to
understand about scaling laws and so on
but I think that that's a a key thing to
understand in terms of the very
practical issues about you know how
small can you make the llms what are the
llms really doing where can they just
make use of computation at sort of the
back end of the llm okay now let's talk
about the secondary thermodynamics so
what is the second rule of
thermodynamics it's it's the sometimes
called the law of entropy increase it's
kind of the law that says when things
start off orderly they tend to end up
more disordered so for example
if you take something like a bunch of
gas molecules or and they're all
initially sort of all in a clump they're
all kind of lined up and then you just
let them bounce around a box before too
long they'll be bouncing around kind of
randomly
so
that's characterized by this idea of
entropy so what is entropy entropy is
basically counting the number of states
of a system that are consistent with
what you know about that system so for
example if all you know is the gas
molecules are all in just in this box
there are many possible configurations
they could have if you know that the gas
molecules are all in this particular
corner of the box there are fewer
configurations they could have because
all the configurations that have gas
molecules not in that corner can't be
there so entropy is is the logarithm
basically of the number of states that
are consistent with what you know about
a system so to say that the entropy
increases which is another statement of
second order Dynamics is to say that
things essentially look more random to
you because the things that you might
say oh it's special the system has these
special characteristics well if the
entropy is increasing it's saying that
it's it's always sort of escaping from
that specialness it's always it's always
more typical less special so to speak so
the question has always been why does
this really happen and here's why it
gets tricky let's say you're talking
about gas molecules well if you knew the
initial configuration of all those gas
molecules you just use Newton's
equations and so on Newton's Laws you
figure out how these gas molecules
bounce around you know exactly where
they're going to land up there's no
question of saying oh the thing got more
random we don't know where the gas
molecules are well no you actually know
exactly where the gas molecules are you
just follow the equations of motion to
see where they go so what is the so so
how does it come to be the case that we
can start to talk about entropy
increasing well people have said for a
long time what you really need to look
at is the coarse grained entropy that is
you need to say not what what particular
configuration of the gas molecules end
up in but is that configuration in some
way special if at the beginning it was
special because all the gas molecules
were a corner in the corner of the Box
does it remain special later on okay so
the big observation is it doesn't remain
special but it's been very hard to
characterize what that means
and here's sort of an analogy if uh oh
and I should explain another thing the
the other another feature of this this
is a complicated subject by the way and
I'm I'm um it um another another feature
of this is that
the um
uh the thing that um is this notion of
irreversibility the notion that things
might start orderly they end up
disordered and never go back so for
example you might have a mechanical
motion where you're moving this big
piece of metal or something that has
gazillions of molecules in it and you're
moving them all together but then some
of that motion gets converted through
friction into heat and the sort of
energy associated with the heat is
something which is just a bunch of
molecules randomly bouncing around and
you never kind of can get that back into
something orderly once the once the
motion has sort of turned into heat
turned into the randomness that's
associated with heat it never goes back
into something more ordered again and
that's what um that's kind of this
phenomenon of irreversibility that you
can that things sort of irreversibly
degrade into into sort of Randomness and
and sort of pure heat and they never go
back the other way
so again
and now why is that confusing it's
confusing because if you look
microscopically at these individual
molecules each individual molecule each
individual Collision
could you could reverse that Collision
so if you had a movie of the individual
collisions you show the movie you can't
tell whether the movie is running
forwards or backwards because every
individual elastic mechanical Collision
can be reversed so the question is why
is it the case that in the aggregate all
of these things end up seeming like
they're going irreversibly towards heat
and never coming back from heat to sort
of mechanical work so this is kind of
this is kind of the the mystery of all
this stuff and and what has sort of come
out is I think we Now understand how
this works I began to understand it back
in the 1980s I think I now really
understand it and uh I'll make a few
other comments about it before sort of
really trying to explain how it works
um I will say that that the first
serious science project I tried to do
back when I was 12 years old was about
this very topic so I'm I'm now at uh you
know t plus 50 years in trying to
understand how this works and just to
tell that story it's a little bit of an
amusing Story I mean I I was I was
interested in physics and so I went and
uh my big excitement from sort of
finishing Elementary School was go get a
bunch of physics textbooks and one of
them had this this cover picture that
showed a bunch of sort of simulated
particles that started on one side of a
box and then kind of randomized and and
filled the box and I was like this is
cool and I you know I read the
description of the second order
thermodynamics that's in that book and
it was like I don't really understand
how this works let me uh try and you
know get a better understanding of it I
thought okay I had just sort of uh found
that the school that I was going to had
a computer was a one of the it was a
thing the size of a desk program with
paper tape with a a whopping eight
kilowatts of memory uh ferrite and core
memory but I thought okay I'm going to
program this thing
um just like you know whoever program it
up for the cover of the book and I only
learned many many years later the story
of how it got put on the cover of the
book it was actually at the time it used
the kind of the world's largest
supercomputer to do those computations
but I didn't know that at that time in
any case the the um so I I said I'm
gonna I'm gonna do this simulation of
these these things so there I am writing
in machine code basically Assembly
Language and trying to do this ending up
sort of simplifying the Dynamics of all
these balls bouncing around to some kind
of just a bunch of bits on a grid and
well it was a disappointment because it
didn't work it didn't show the same
picture as was on the cover of the book
so I was like okay that didn't work I
went off and worked on particle physics
and cosmology and a bunch of other
things and started building uh computer
languages and and so on and um
then kind of many years later I came
back to this question and I realized
that actually it had worked I think I
don't unfortunately I'm not sure I have
the program anymore I have some paper
tapes that I used on that machine but
it's not really that easy to read a
paper tape anymore and worse than that I
wrote a paper tape loader which is the
actual encoding thing that encodes the
way that the paper tape works I don't
have the code of my loader anymore and
so that that gives an even even greater
level of difficulty in figuring out
what's going on but in any case the um
well
I think I saw you you did you fixed that
simulation at least because I saw and um
I don't remember if it was one of your
books or or articles where if you take
those that like Square block and you
have and you're using like Square
molecules and you just add like a little
bit of nudges or offsets or things like
that then you then you get the behavior
that one would expect that's kind of
entropic mixing right yeah actually the
the thing that I think I did back on
when I was using that paper tape
computer was even more like a cellular
automaton like something with it's just
a grid of positions rather than rather
than having continuous positions
um but yes absolutely the the at this
point now I understand how this all
works but when I was 12 13 years old I
didn't
um but before we get it because you said
some really interesting things and
before we get too far from the
irreversibility aspect I'd like to pick
your brain on that because sure this has
been one of the most enduring Mysteries
right of of modern physics is that all
our laws are reverse
and yet the behavior that we observe in
the universe is manifestly irreversible
and I guess there's there's been kind of
two solutions to that one is to say well
maybe there is some intrinsic
irreversibility in the laws right that
in in the time Evolution this sort of
thing that's one possibility another is
that long long ago the big bang and the
distant distant past was just very
special it was this ultra low entropy
State and therefore that's why we have
this appearance you know apparent motion
if you will Dynamics away from this low
entropy to a high entropy so I'm curious
in kind of your your physics project in
the rule space and the in the evolution
that you imagine on the hypergraph which
is it is it that the distant past was
unique or that the laws are irreversible
that's complicated okay so so there are
several different things going on okay
and um but the most immediate one is the
following thing essentially what's
happening in you know just gas molecules
let's forget the early Universe for a
second we're going to come back to the
early Universe because it's very
interesting but um just gas molecules
bouncing around in a box the um
the thing that um uh the I think the
right way to think about it is it's like
encryption
you have these initial conditions they
can be quite special
but the and when these gas molecules
Bounce Around they're effectively doing
a computation to work out where the gas
molecules will end up
that computation we can think of as like
an encryption of the initial conditions
the the data about the initial
conditions is still absolutely there
they're still reversibility if we if we
did the computation backwards we would
get those initial conditions so why is
it that we don't notice that well the
problem is because the positions of the
gas molecules in effect have been
encrypted and so when we look at the
output if we're not great cryptanalysts
we can't do we can't see that inversion
when we just come and we measure it and
we just have our simple ways of
measuring things it just looks random to
us we don't we're not able to do the
cryptanalysis to see how to go backwards
and so I think the essential phenomenon
is this interplay between the
computational process what I call
computational irritation disability of
the actual dynamics of the molecules
coupled with the computational
boundedness of our ability to observe
things so when we make observations
we're always taking lots of detail and
we're aggregating it together like when
we look out at you know the scene that
I'm looking at right now there are you
know there are lots of photons falling
on the retina of my eye there's lots of
nerve impulses but in the end I'm just
I'm looking at a camera that's the
that's the thing my brain is thinking
I'm taking all that detail and I'm kind
of aggregating it down to this one
factor I'm looking at this camera and by
the way I'm not working out every
individual pixel and doing this very
complicated computation on them I'm just
averaging them in some simple way and so
you know I think the the core of the
second law is this interplay between the
underlying computational process which
is kind of like doing this encryption
and the the way that we observe it which
is we are limited in our ability our
minds are kind of and our sensory
apparatus and our measuring devices are
limited in their sort of computational
ability they can't follow every
individual molecule they can't do that
that cryptanalysis to find out where it
came from now when I talk about sort of
the the Dynamics of the system
encrypting its initial conditions the
way we have to think about it is the the
process of of physical process of
molecules bouncing around and so on
that's like a computation now the
question is can is it like a computation
where we can just jump ahead and say and
the answer is 42 or is it a computation
where the only way we can know the
answer is by doing every step in the
computation and one of the things that I
discovered in the 1980s and and uh have
sort of built a lot on top of is this
idea of computational irreducibility
that there are many computations even
one specified by incredibly time tiny
programs which have this feature that
you really can't reduce them you can't
jump ahead and say and the answer is
going to be this you'll really just
stuck going through every step in the
computation in fact I mean this
phenomenon of computationally
reducibility is I think one that is sort
of a tremendously important sort of
piece of Science and intuition because
it's the thing that kind of tells you
science isn't going to be able to give
you all the answers science as what we
have thought about in terms of it's just
this thing where we feed in the input
and we immediately make a prediction
that's not going to work you know that
has many implications for AI for example
if you say I'm going to set up the rules
for my Ai and I'm going to get them just
right so that I can know that my AI is
never going to do the wrong thing okay
computational irreducibility says it's
just not going to work you're just never
going to know there are always going to
be things where to know what it's going
to do you have to just run it and see
what it does and so that phenomenon of
computational irreducibility that's what
happens with gas molecules and it's our
inability to sort of do all that
elaborate computation that means that we
perceive what's happening to be you
start off with these very orderly gas
molecules but you end up with something
that looks random at least to us at
least to the computationally bounded us
now yeah when I mean so that's I think
the core of what's going on it's it's
this process uh of of sort of
computational irreducibility underneath
and our sort of limited computational
abilities
um kind of at the top now you know I I
will say that that I mean this is gosh
we this this gets quite deep quite
quickly but but um
um the um
one of the things okay so uh in in 20th
century physics there were sort of three
big theories
uh general relativity theory of
space-time quantum mechanics and
statistical mechanics theory of what
happens with lots of lots of molecules
and so on and the the sort of the key
result of statistical mechanics is the
second law of thermodynamics
and what people have thought in the
1800s was well statistical mechanics and
the second law in particular we're going
to be able to derive that from
sort of the mechanics of molecules
there's just going to be some way in
which the mechanics of molecules
inevitably leads to the second law but
they didn't think that general
relativity would be of that character
nor do they think quantum mechanics will
be of that character they thought those
things would be things that were just
well the universe happens to be set up
that way we don't get to derive those
kinds of things the thing that for me is
just I'm really excited about is that I
think we Now understand that all three
of those theories are in the same sense
derivable and they all come from the
same phenomenon which to me is just well
if you're in the physical business I
think that's spectacular but and so and
this for not it's the phenomenon of the
interplay between computational
irreducibility of underlying processes
and our feature as Observers the fact
that we are observers that are the way
we are with our kind of computationally
bounded abilities and so on is that
happens to be the way we are we could
imagine the aliens so to speak who work
differently but we work this way and so
the thing that we then discover is in
the case of space-time what we now think
is that the Universe at a sufficiently
small scale is made of discrete atoms of
space that are related by this kind of
hypograph and as sort of the the process
time is the process of the progressive
rewriting of that typograph time is the
computational process the passage of
time is the execution of the computation
that is those pieces of the hypograph
getting Rewritten but we don't perceive
space as a bunch of atoms of space in a
hypograph we perceive Continuum space
the fact that we perceive Continuum
space is because we are making sort of
computationally bounded observation we
are averaging out all those individual
atoms of space because at our scale
we're a hundred orders of magnitude may
be bigger than the atoms of space so we
don't get to sort of see oh there's one
atom here one atom there we just
aggregate all of those things so we're
observing sort of Space sets continuous
because we are observers of the kind we
are and it turns out that the other
important Criterion about us as
observers is that we are observers who
believe we are persistent in time so in
our models the you know we are made of
these atoms of space every moment in
time we're sort of getting Rewritten
into new atoms of space but we believe
we have a consistent thread of
experience and those two facts turn out
to give one the equations for general
relativity when applied to you know when
you do the kind of the mathy stuff
underneath
and and it turns out the same story
happens in quantum mechanics anyway the
the end result is that this sort of
boundedness of the Observer is is kind
of inter interacting with the underlying
computational irreducibility seems to
tell us that we inevitably as observers
like us it's inevitable that we perceive
physics to be the way it is now I might
just add something here that that Loops
into machine learning and Ai and so on
because here's the thing we really need
we need a theory of the Observer you
know we can say well an observer is
something that kind of takes a lot of
detail about the world and kind of uh
sort of uh
averages it down or equivalences it down
to make a definite conclusion in other
words we bring in lots of input in our
brains but then in the end we we we boil
all that down to say am I going to make
a decision about what to do next
and I think the essential feature of
observers like us is this idea of we
taking a lot of data in and we're kind
of making a decision from that and I
think that that already we can see that
even knowing just a little bit about how
observers like us work allows us to
derive things about how physics has to
appear to us but as we figure out more
about what observers like us are like
we will find out that there are more
things that are inevitably the way they
appear to be for observers like us about
physics and so why does this relate to
things like you know machine learning
and AI because a pretty good model for
an observer like us is probably a neural
net it's not a bad model and neural Nets
immediately have the feature that you
can have lots of inputs coming in and
you can have kind of a a small number of
attractors as the output you can have
sort of a classifier that says that all
these things coming in there's only
going to be the small number of things
coming out and that that's that's sort
of a a an approximate model for this now
you know there are when you when you try
and work this out well so so one of the
things I'm working on right now is
trying to build what I call Observer
Theory and and kind of the idea is when
you think about computation we have kind
of a minimal model of computation
something like Turing machines which try
to sort of take all the details of how
you might make it with electronic
circuits so Bank clerks or whatever else
and we say here's a minimal model we're
trying to make a similar minimal model
for what an observer is like because I
think that knowing interesting those
characteristics is going to show us it's
inevitable okay so the real test is can
we derive the number three by which I
mean we know that we perceive space to
be three-dimensional
is that a consequence of the way that we
are as Observers is that something where
a dice was thrown dye was was thrown and
the you know our particular Universe got
the number three or is the fact that we
observe three dimensions nothing to do
with that and a feature of the way that
we are as observers like if we were and
you start thinking about what are things
about us as observers that seem
completely obvious to us but we haven't
necessarily captured like like here's an
example uh an example is the world has
there are the what what an individual
Observer like us observes is whatever
they internally observe but we have this
belief that there are other Minds out
there that are like ours
that is something which is kind of
obvious to us it's like we it's like
well obviously that's true but if you
start trying to formalize that idea that
probably has consequences for what for
characterizing us as observers and there
are there are many uh give you another
example
one thing that's special about us as
observers is that our brains operate
slowly compared to the speed of light
what does this mean it means that if I'm
looking around you know I see maybe a
hundred feet away from me or something
like that the light that comes from 100
feet away from me comes to me in you
know 100 nanoseconds or something and
that's really short compared to the
milliseconds that it takes my brain to
know what an earth happened so why does
that have a consequence
the fact that things are set up that way
is why we believe that space exists that
that sort of there's a a state of the
universe and space at successive moments
in time because we've kind of gulped in
the whole of our space that we can see
and then we get to that that's One
Moment In Time the next moment in time
and so on if we were much bigger than we
are for example we would not have this
perception we would we would that and if
our brains work to a different speed we
would say no no you know you can't just
say there's this whole of space at a
particular moment in time you've got to
parse apart or space at different
moments in time so there's a lot of
these kind of features of of the way we
happen to be as observers that I think
lead to the physics that we observe and
it's kind of a an interesting thing that
that I think we get to use the success
of modern you know machine learning AI
type things to to now have an actual
model that that we can now start to feed
in to sort of say well this is a
reasonably accurate model of how brains
work at least for these purposes so
let's use that to find some fundamental
science from that
so wonderful
there's this this is a very deep subject
I'm sorry I could go for sure
ages and ages and ages but um and I'm
also uh you know it's it's to me
the the set of things that are sort of
falling into place it's just amazing I
mean it's it's you know we're starting
to have simulations of black hole
mergers based on the sweet space and so
on we're starting to we're I think
finally I can start to say actually I
understand quantum mechanics I
understand you know what's going to work
and not work with quantum computers I
mean to say that very easily you know
quantum mechanics is the story of how
there are multiple possible histories
for the universe and you get these
branching and merging sort of Paths of
history for the universe and sort of the
big the big hack of quantum Computing is
let's leverage that and let's use those
different branching histories of the
universe to run different computations
in each branch
and that's absolutely fine you can
absolutely do that there's one problem
we observers of the universe believe
that definite things happen so somehow
you have to take all those branches that
ran their separate computations you have
to knit them back together again and say
uh kind of and say okay the human
observed it and this is what actually
happened and the problem is that's hard
and this again relates to this whole
Observer Theory question of just and you
start realizing and by the way it also
relates to kind of quantite a Quantum
version of neural Nets where you have
the different sort of branches of what
can happen in the neural Nets that live
on these different branches of History
so to speak and you have this notion of
what we call branchial space which is
kind of the the space of possible
branches and we as Minds embedded in the
universe one of the weird things is we
span a region of branchial space so we
don't we actually are aggregate
irrigating together different branches
of history and you can start to say how
does that actually work as you as you
make a neural net that has that sort of
has an extension in branchial space that
means that many different possible
things are happening in that neural net
that's you know machine learning is
difficult enough as it is llms are
complicated enough as they are getting
the quantum version where you have many
branches of history is yet another level
of complexity but it's one that um that
I think is relevant for understanding
sort of how how we perceive things but
anyway I could yeah I could uh there's
there's a lot to say about this yeah
one more thing before before we kind of
um leave this subject and it has to do
with a thing that we see in llms and
we're also seeing and sort of thinking
about physics and the universe and so on
and it's the following thing let's see
so one of the mysteries about sort of
physics the universe Etc is let's say
we've got this computational model we
found the machine code for the universe
and we hold it up and we say here's the
machine code for the universe it's this
set of rules then you'll immediately say
well why did we get this particular set
of rules and not another one
I found that very confusing why did we
get you know rule number 317 as opposed
to rule something else
so what I realized at some point a
couple years ago now uh what came out of
our work is is that that um
really you should think about the
universe as running all possible rules
we have this notion of what we call the
rouliad which is this thing where you're
running all possible computations in a
kind of entangled way so think about you
start off all possible Turing machines
with all possible rules for the turing
machine all possible initial States for
the turing machine you let that whole
thing just run now
two different turing machine States
could evolve to the same turing machine
state so you have both sort of and the
same turing machine State could evolve
to two different states so you get this
kind of branching merging big giant mess
this big giant mess represents all
possible computations every possible
computation is in there now the thing
that gets very sort of Mind twisting is
we are part of this ruly ad so our story
of what we observe in our experience is
kind of the uh the the the thing
embedded within the rouliad observing
the rouliad and that's why this Observer
Theory stuff is so important because it
means that we know that we are a certain
kind of we are taking a certain kind of
sampling of the rouliad and once we know
something about that sampling we can say
what consequences it has so one feature
of this picture is within the rouliad
you can be an observer sort of at
different points than the rulia just
like in physical space we can live on
earth we could live on Mars we can live
in different places we can have a
different point of view about our
experience of the universe so similarly
in the rouliad our minds can effectively
position be positioned at different
places in the rouliad each different
position is like having a different
point of view about the rules that exist
in the universe so you have this idea of
kind of Minds at different places in the
rouliad so different human Minds might
be quite nearby you know by the time you
get to animal mines they're further away
Etc et cetera et cetera okay so here's
the really funky thing
so
question is how do two minds communicate
these two mines are different places in
real space they're trying to communicate
with each other
if we think about knowing that's we've
got two different neural Nets they've
encoded the universe in different ways
you can't just do a brain transplant
where you say I'm going to take the
weights from one neural net and stick
them into the other neural it's not
going to work there's some there's some
sort of layer of there's some interface
layer you need
so in the case the in the case of
physical space the way you sort of
communicate across physical space is to
send particles like photons or electrons
and those are sort of a packaging of the
structure of space that are sort of
persistent through time and through
space they can just move from one place
to another without changing so now in
rule space what's the analog of that
well the bizarre thing is I think the
analog of that is a concept
that is that a concept is something you
can take from one mind and it's sort of
packaged up enough like a particle that
you can kind of move it to another mind
and unpack it again and it'll still sort
of be the same kind of thing in other
words the the raw weights and effect
aren't a concept the raw weights are
just you know the the at like the atoms
of space but by the time you've packaged
it into a concept you have something
that is this Con is sort of
transportable and so that that starts to
ask questions about sort of an llm
science level what is the you know what
is the what is the notion of what a
concept looks like in kind of llm
Science and so on so this is this is how
some of these things perhaps get
connected yes yeah so just a touch there
are so many things that you said that
um my God almost don't know where to
start but yeah the um the the thing that
really strikes me is how similar so many
of these ideas are
um to what what we hear from other
scientists so for example Carl friston
talks about Markov blankets in terms of
you know you have these things that have
agency and Daniel Dennett talks about
the intentional stance which is what
does it mean to have agentiveness and um
and of course you're talking as well
about Concepts and and we speak to
cognitive scientists that talk about
what does it mean to be a concept we
speak with um uh you know evolutionary
psychologists who have this very
ecological view that you're just
speaking to because you can think of
rule your space as being a kind of
cognitive ecology
um but with a very different manifold so
all of these ideas are very very similar
and the the agentiveness thing in
particular what you call the Observer is
fascinating and I recommend folks read
your new book because in the first
chapter you spoke a lot about the
computational limitations of observers
and in respect of the equivalence
principle you were talking about how you
can't un you know you can't outrun rule
30 you know that there are kind of speed
limits in in rule space and when I was
speaking last night he was talking about
um is there only one big bang are there
multiple Big Bangs in in rural your
space but anyway we should try and keep
this structured because we're so short
on time I wanted to speak about my pet's
topic which is language so I've just
read this fascinating book called The
Language game and it's by Morton
Christensen and and Nick chater and
essentially they say that um
you know language emerged from a social
cognitive ability so we have this
ability to play charades using a
combination of single signals so vocal
and visual uh but also with pointers to
Shared cultural and social knowledge or
you could say ruly or knowledge and you
know they argue to some extent language
is is culture and culture is language
it's a symbiotic organism it's parasitic
on humans it evolves faster than our DNA
it literally has a life of its own and
um what's really fascinating is people
like Chomsky say oh you know there's
this Global structure of grammar we're
taught in schools that um language is
declining and that there's this
puritanical
um kind of universal form of language
but of course it's not like that at all
is it so we have all of these low-level
interactions and this apparent structure
emerges and as you were just speaking
about with the conceivability problem
similar to Nagel's bat we we have this
notion that there are other Minds out
there and we have this notion that
there's a kind kind of information
geometry you know that when we train
something like a large language model it
gives us interesting responses it's
almost like there's a framework of how
we conceive and think of things in the
universe and that's very much what is
happening in in this kind of weird
nebulous
um kind of linguistic dance that happens
in our culture and our language making
so could you talk to how that structure
emerges
yeah I mean so one thing to understand
is what is there all together in the
computational universe in this kind of
in the ruly ad so to speak all together
there's all possible computations
most of them we humans don't yet care
about
I say yet because we progressively
colonize more and more of rural space as
we as we discover more ways to measure
things as we think about more ways to
think about things we are sort of
expanding in rural space but we are at a
absolutely microscopic fraction of of
the of the space so I'll give you an
example I I had this thing I wrote
recently that I was referring to as the
cat's blog because it has pictures of
cats all over it but it's it's about the
mental imagery of alien minds and it's
kind of an application of generative AI
to sort of a fundamental philosophical
question and the question is uh kind of
what
how does an alien mind view the world
and so the the you know what I was
actually doing was looking at you know
we've got the prompt for a generative AI
you know a cat in a party hat okay
imagine we change the generative AI we
change its mind what does it think a cat
and a party hat is like when its mind is
different and you can start seeing you
know how does that how does it how does
it perceive that but a different
question you can ask is you know you
turn a cat in a party hat into some
embedding at some you know length of
thousand Vector of numbers you just
start looking at you know what happens
as you move away from what I was calling
Cat Island so you know there's this
place where the embedding is exactly the
right embedding for a cat and a party
hat you've got a picture of a cat and a
party hat you you change it just a
little bit you're moving off the island
of the concept of a cat and a party hat
and it's really kind of an interesting
thing because you know the particular
models I was using the part of the space
that is populated by Concepts we know is
one part in 10 to the 600. so in other
words 10 to the minus 600 of the space
is Concepts we've ever heard of and the
rest is what I call inter-concept space
kind of the analog of interstellar space
so to speak the bulk you know what's
that the bulk yeah the bulk space yeah
the it's it's a it's kind of the the
so we're you know what's in into concept
space they're things we humans could
care about but we don't yet I mean and
that's a that's a small part that's a
tiny tiny slice of what's out there in
the full rouliad that's that's really
things where it was sort of already
trained on human images and and this and
that and the other but so this question
of what's you know what's there now in
into concept space we might decide we're
gonna we're gonna build a city in into
concept space we're going to take this
set of images for example and we're
going to give it a name is what happened
with fractals for example people had
made nested images they'd seen them
probably in nature back in the 1200s
people were making nested images nobody
knew what they were the art historians
just ignore those that you know the
mosaics that looked like they were
nested and it took until until you know
the 20th century before people said well
there's a thing you know that we care
about and it's called we call it
fractals and now you're sort of building
the city in and into concept space and
that becomes a concept that we talk
about so to speak so I think that's the
you know in a sense a lot of our
progression as a sort of intellectual
species so to speak comes by by sort of
colonizing and how do we do this
colonization what do we do we put down
you know we stake a claim and the main
way we stick a claim is we for example
make up a word for something we say this
is and then and that becomes our kind of
network and it's a it's it is as you say
a very social thing in the sense that if
I make up a word for something and
nobody else has ever heard that word it
doesn't do me much good it's like if I
can't send that rule ill particle out
from me and expect that somebody else
can decode that really old particle it's
not going to do me any good in terms of
communication and I think let me just
ask you a really quick question about
this because
um it's something that's come up so many
times we're super curious about imagine
out there in the universe or other
Ascension alien species of comparable or
greater you know IQ or whatnot do you
think that they arrive at the same or
very similar sets of basic concepts like
assume they're computationally bounded
maybe to a similar order of magnitude is
a set of Concepts that you arrive at
driven by chance or is it driven by
really how bounded you are
computationally well that's really
interesting question I mean look the in
terms of the laws of physics we kind of
know at this point that with observers
like us
they will necessarily have the same laws
of physics
but when you get to more detailed things
I think all bets are off as we saw you
know we represent 10 to the minus 600 of
the event a concept space even with this
very you know us oriented version of you
know map you know version of
inter-concept space so the chance that
we hit the same Concepts I think is low
but this is where Observer theory is
important because we have to say an
observer okay let's talk about an
observer like us what is an observer
like us so so for example the individual
neurons in our brains are probably not
observers like us the aggregate of all
our neurons is an observer like us
but let's take Society for example the
aggregate of a billion humans what's
that like we say well what's the
Observer what kind of Observer is an ant
colony like each individual ant we say
well each individual ant kind of has an
experience it's a bit like ours but
actually it's more like saying that the
ant colony is like the whole of human
society and what's sort of interesting
there is just like we humans make
decisions we take all those 100 billion
neurons we have in our brains and the
result is the next word we say is blah
then similarly Human Society every so
often sometimes for better sometimes For
Worse essentially makes decisions and
there are you know the line in the
history book says and then humans did
this and it wasn't every individual
human did whatever you know just like
every individual nerve cell does
different things but in aggregate the
humans did this we've kind of got this
Society level Observer that's
determining the that's that's that's
reflected in the course of history and
you know I think that this this question
of sort of how do we get into what you
know what are the concepts relevant for
a different kind of Observer very
interesting question and uh you know the
concepts relevant for the dog the
concepts relevant for the whale you know
we don't know and and you're asking will
they land the same place uh you know
biologically related organisms maybe
they have so much in common I mean we we
that that there will be certain things
that necessarily land in the same place
we we think that's probably true with
emotions probably our neurotransmitters
are similar enough that you know the
dogs have and this is something Darwin
pointed out that dogs have a similar
sort of spectrum of emotions to us
humans perhaps because we have similar
neurotransmitters and so on well what I
was more curious about was I was
imagining other other species that could
perform the same or greater Feats of
engineering you know the control of
space and physics and and you can
imagine that in order to do that in
order to colonize the stars for example
you probably need to discover something
similar to Newtonian mechanics and
general relativity and quantum mechanics
and so I'm just wondering if they would
arrive at those kinds of same higher
level scientific Concepts or if they
could come up with radically different
you know sciences that bear no
relationship whatsoever to ours and yet
are equally successful I think the issue
is what do you mean by colonize by the
time you say colonizing the humans where
you put Flags in places
you already cooking the goose so to
speak so for example I would say the
photons of the universe have colonized
it
you know photons have gone everywhere in
the universe it didn't even take any
time as far as the photons are concerned
okay well fair enough it isn't so so in
other words the the what you're asking
for is if you say you know you're going
to have a spacecraft that shows up and
it looks like one of our spacecraft and
it's not and and it's got you know
different you know Minds inside it that
are acting somewhat differently and so
on it's not something that is just uh
gas molecules let me give you an example
it relates back to the second order of
thermodynamics people sometimes worry
about the heat death of the universe
that over the course of time everything
that's now in the universe is going to
just end up as a bunch of random
molecules bouncing around they say what
a disaster everything's over then in the
universe it's maximized it's entropy
it's all random there's nothing there
but that really isn't correct it's only
correct to an observer like us to an
observer capable of tracing all those
molecules it's like no no no the
universe has this amazing collection of
things going on that are that are um uh
that are kind of um you know that you
can see in all these molecules bouncing
around it's only to an observer like us
that it seems boring so it's really a
question of what what are you kind of
signing up for as as an observer there's
so so much of this reminds me of um Carl
friston's free energy principle so at
the at the base I think of um rulior
space as as being a kind of structured
topology of of information but there's
no agentiveness so what fristian does is
he speaks about these Markov boundaries
and you can have boundaries of culture
of planets of people so this kind of
hierarchy of boundaries and they are
actually based on the the second law of
Thermodynamics it's all about these
things that can maintain their own
existence they can maintain entropy
they've got all of these entropic forces
acting on them but they can maintain
their own existence in this sea of of
disorder but you see what I'm saying
agentiveness is built into his system um
and when you speak about the theory of
observers it's almost like you need to
build it on top of yours
maybe I need to have a chat with Mr
friston I think you do we would like to
put we would like to arrange that yeah
maybe we should do that I you know his
his name's come up a bunch of times it's
always such a challenge because all of
us build uh as you know all of us build
these big sort of conceptual towers and
sometimes you know you have to make this
assessment you know I I know about many
conceptual Towers I don't know about all
of them and uh you know sometimes it's
it's sort of disappointing because you
say there's this big conceptual town
it's got all these great names
associated with it and then you look at
it and it's like no that was kind of
trivial from my point of view but but
it's it's some you know I think that
there are a lot of different um I mean
one of the things that for me is always
a a uh a great kind of controller of of
sort of uh you know where is one going
is can you make it computational can you
write code and you know to me there's a
lot of things where it's kind of like
debated by philosophers theologians
whatever else for thousands of years and
one day you've got to write code that
just does it and you know we're going to
see that a lot with kind of AI
governance a lot of things debated for
for thousands of years in political
philosophy in the end you've got to
write code and um you know that's a to
me that's a very interesting to me you
know as I have to say as as I uh you
know work on a bunch of these things and
and try and figure out things like this
Observer Theory thing to me it's kind of
like the thing that grounds it is always
and then you've got to write code and
can you actually can you actually see
what's happening and that that's that
always helps me and so you know when for
example people are always telling me
that aspect of what we talk about sort
of resonate with various different
cultural traditions of thinking and so
on they're not cultural Traditions that
I know and so that's it's very difficult
often to kind of wrap one's brain around
those things and and it's like if it
turns into code I kind of then we have a
common ground you know our computers you
know both of our computers can
understand it but yeah so I I'm I'm not
um I'm not well equipped to uh uh to
talk about this although I although as
you correctly stated at the beginning of
this um of this conversation I I have a
a very great uh uh sort of appetite for
learning about things it's it's always
just a question of of I mean to me also
and this is not actually unrelated to
some of these theoretical questions I
can't learn stuff unless I have a
framework into which to put it so if
people say you know in eastern mysticism
I'll give you an example you know it's
like when you you know the the sort of
the goal in the end is is quotes not to
exist there's been a sort of a thing
people sometimes summarize some kinds of
you know Eastern Traditions are saying
and I realized at some point that uh
actually I've run into the same thing
because as you think about rule space
and you think about us as sort of
entities in that you say we're expanding
our domain we're we're kind of exploring
more and more of a real space we're very
proud of ourselves we're colonizing more
and more rural space we're going to get
to the point where we've got the whole
ruli ad they say well wait a minute what
does that mean well it basically means
we no longer coherently exist because
coherent existence requires this kind of
this this kind of concentration into
particular points of view about how the
universe works and so I sort of realized
on whether it's really true but I I
don't know whether there's a
correspondence between those different
ways of thinking but to me it's sort of
interesting that from this thing that
comes out of a bunch of essentially you
know theoretical computation uh one ends
up with something which has some
resonance at least with the thing people
talk about in uh in kind of a culturally
different way of thinking so to speak we
announced the um the Epic launch of the
chat GPT plugin last time and you have
dedicated pretty much most of your
career to the very notion of language
design which is why you have so much
deep intuition about it indeed you think
about it almost as a kind of language of
thought it kind of it's um it places
guard rails on on what is conceivable to
us and you've spent decades designing
the Wolfram language which and now we've
got this thing where we do retrieval
augmented generation and we have these
human utterances and we generate Wolfram
code I read a paper recently about some
of the failure modes with that so first
of all it you know let's comment on the
successes and the failures of that but
but also how the Wolfram language could
evolve potentially to be
um a better interface to to Ai and just
your thoughts on on language design in
general yeah you know one of the fun
things that llms have done for us is you
know I'm very keen on figuring out what
are the lumps of computational work that
people think are worth worth doing and
having and I have to say one of the ways
that llms have been helping recently
which just really surprises me is as
they write wolf and language code they
hallucinate function names but actually
it's really useful to look at those
hallucinated names and we're just
implementing a few of the names that
basically gpt4 made up that's hilarious
consistently makes up because it has
correctly divided find something which
is sort of part of the Zeitgeist of what
humans seem to want so to speak so it's
a it's a that's a that's a useful thing
now you know I've been uh so that's
that's kind of a fun thing on the side
but the thing that is really emerging is
a very interesting workflow we have this
notion of chat notebooks where uh it
works really nicely actually this kind
of notebook concept of ours back from
um that we've had all that time of kind
of this you know code and and text and
so on and this you know hierarchical
organization of this well now we have
chat cells where you can be sending
those to an llm and from the chat cell
you can generate code and what you see
happening is okay we also have this
symbolic representation of tools so just
like you can have in woven language you
can have a symbolic representation of an
AP of an API you can also have a
symbolic representation of a tool that
the that will be provided for the llm to
use
so it's really pretty cool you you'll
you'll type something in in natural
language and uh it'll start up and it'll
start trying to write well from language
code it'll run that code it'll look at
the results sometimes iterates a whole
bunch of times just like a human
programmer might do saying well I
thought that was right but actually no
it's wrong it'll keep going we're
gradually learning more and more about
how to have that whole Loop work better
you know it's um there's a we're
learning I think just put in the last
couple of weeks a thing which is read
the blank documentation you know when
certain things go wrong because one
thing's very interesting is when things
go wrong we have lots of internal
Telemetry about why the code didn't you
know went off track lots of error
messages lots of Stack traces and so on
humans don't bother to look at those
things but we can feed those to the llm
and that's really interesting because
the llm can then go and say you know oh
what went wrong was this which a human
would have taken a long time to dig
through and find out and it can
sometimes just feed it back for itself
and say okay now I'm going to fix this
code I'm going to I'm going to keep
going so that's a that's a really uh a
useful thing but the the thing that kind
of this this uh it is fun that it gets
to states there where basically if you
were looking over a human's shoulder you
would say read the documentation now and
that's what we're telling it to do too
and it works nicely and it's some now
having said that
it's what's the real workflow here I
mean the you know I say something in
vague natural language and by the way I
find even myself getting sloppier and
sloppier as I talk to the llm it's like
if you really want to do a good prompt
engineering if you really want to write
good prompts you've got to have your
expository writing hat on that that's
the way you're actually going to write a
good prompt and I find whenever I get
sloppy which I do very quickly as I'm
talking to it because it's kind of
working nicely it's like well I'm just
typing random things at it which I which
are kind of what come to my mind first
and it's then giving me woven language
code I look at the code and I say that's
not what I meant and it's like but if I
look at the words I wrote
it will be perfectly reasonable to
interpret them to be what it interprets
them to be but the whole point is I get
to see the Wolfram language code which
is a computational language that I can
read and I get to say wait a minute that
wasn't what I intended and I can either
tell it that wasn't what I intended and
kind of have it try and clean it up or I
can have it or I can just edit it myself
and the workflow that I see really
emerging is and I think it's going to be
most relevant for sort of on-ramping of
people doing things they've never done
before where it's just like I have a
concept in my mind and I want to kind of
get my computer to do it and I just can
can yak about it but I don't really know
how to start writing the code and then
you just tell it to the llm it will
write something you'll look at it and
say no you missed the point you've got
or you didn't completely miss the point
you gave me a big piece of it but you
got a piece of it wrong so now I can
kind of clean that up maybe with the
help of the llm that becomes this sort
of solid brick that I can now stop
building this whole Tower of
capabilities on and I think that's a
really good model and I think that um uh
you know I think I don't know I haven't
used it yet myself as much as I might
like I've done some oh like here's a
bizarre thing I was trying to translate
uh some Pascal code that somebody gave
me on an eight inch floppy disk in 1982.
and um okay so I'm like okay llm can you
translate this Pascal code into woven
language and it did something it was
useful it was better it got me started I
mean I looked at it myself but but it
was it was kind of like I was like I
don't know where to even start on this
um you know yeah I'm I'm finding it
useful in the same way which is it's a
great tool for getting me started and
then and there you have to apply the
human intellect and refinement and your
expert knowledge
um but so let me ask you if you don't
mind I guess probably our final question
which is is someone who is on the really
the the bleeding edge of the most
advanced machine learned you know
systems llms as well as the most
advanced symbolic computational systems
and the interface of those two you know
people have been worried enough recently
about just llms and now we got llms
combined with like that symbolic
capability they're they're worried about
Ai and AI risk and you know does it pose
a risk to human beings perhaps even an
existential risk and Congress is
debating whether they need to regulate
it and ban open source and even have air
strikes on Rogue Data Centers and you
know things like that I'm just I'm
curious what's good science fiction
and believe it or not like it's serious
people have thought about it which is
scary yeah but I guess my question to
you is where do you fall on the spectrum
of how much of a risk to
humans in general is is a AI AGI if we
get to that and what if anything should
we be doing about it now to protect
ourselves right I mean first thing to
say is the rouliad is Big we care about
only small parts of it if we leave AIS
to their own devices they're just going
to go out and explore other parts of the
rouliad and do things we absolutely
don't care about and don't understand so
you know what we've done is we've made
AIS in our own image and a lot of what
happens with AIS is sort of reflection
back of us so we people say things like
well what do you want the AIS to do how
should they behave what should the
general guidelines be and people might
say well just you know follow the
guidelines humans follow then people say
no no you don't want to do what humans
do humans do all kinds of crazy stuff we
want the AIS to do what humans aspire to
do we want to and then you're in a
horrible slippery slope of not knowing
what an earth you what on Earth that
means so now you start to say well
you know okay so first point about about
sort of the the AI risk I mean you know
actuation is where things start to get
wild when when the AI is just doing what
the AI does
in a box
it's just doing what it does it's like
when I was using alarms and I I suddenly
I'm about to connect it to Orphan
language you know running on my computer
and I'm about to sort of press the
button to get the thing so that it can
write arbitrary code that just runs
autonomously on my computer that's the
moment where I'm thinking wait a minute
this is maybe not such a good idea
because I have no idea what the llm is
going to write and it's going to have
access to all my file system and
everything removable go very wrong
um and so you know it's that actuation
layer where things the things matter now
some of the actuation is kind of tricky
because some of the actuation is through
humans like if the AIS provide humans
with all kinds of you know incendiary
content and that causes the humans to go
do crazy things that's the AIS using not
a robot arm but us humans as their way
to actuate things so so you know the
actuational error is important I think
that the um this question you know where
you say well what were the AIS do of
their own accord by themselves well
they'll spiral out into the
computational universe and do things we
don't understand and don't care about a
little bit how the natural world just
sort of does lots of stuff that we don't
necessarily care about so I think you
know the question of how you connect AIS
to actuation is an interesting one I
think that sort of as uh you know AI
will get more and more prevalent you
know one of the things that really
strikes me I've just been doing a little
history project looking a lot a lot of
things people wrote around the 19 early
1960s including about Ai and it is
shocking how similar the things people
said about AI in 1963 for example you
could take what somebody said and almost
verbatim it still works today in terms
of in terms of the kinds of things
people are discussing even though a lot
of the things that they were like well
concretely AI is going to do this this
and this well check mark we did that now
we did that we did that but this kind of
General view of there's this kind of um
this General view of what AI might be
and and what what was realizing is that
sort of computation is a very powerful
thing we humans are biting off just a
small piece of it that we care about and
that's kind of the uh that's we sort of
keep on reflecting on what what it is
that we we are seeing there and it
relates again to this thing about
language and the fact that you know
languages our encapsulation of things we
care about versus things we don't I I
think uh well okay so a couple of things
to say one is about kind of you know
will the AIS put everybody out of work
well the answer is if you look at
history the repeated pattern has been
that at first lots of people do one
thing like lots of people are doing
agriculture then that gets automated and
what happens is things get more
fragmented that that you zero out or
very you know make negligible the time
used for that you know pulling plows
around or something like this and but
instead you've got oh the people who are
making bread the people who are doing
this the people who are doing that so
similarly now there are a bunch of
functions which we have had to do step
by step step by step and which are now
getting zeroed out I mean one of the
ones that I've certainly been aware of
for decades is programming where you
know the thing I've been trying to do
for a long time is effectively automate
programming as much as possible yet
people are still writing line by line
step-by-step code and it's like I don't
know why people have been doing that for
decades actually I mean it's it's always
seemed kind of pathological because you
know certainly many sort of Leading Edge
folks who use our technology stack and
so on don't do that and you know like
all this stuff about physics that I've
done no way would I have been able to do
that writing kind of low-level
procedural code and so on with with all
these different things and so on you
know what I've been able to do is
something that kind of recurses on the
things that we've already built so to
speak and I think one of the things that
people are sort of being shocked by is
gosh if you say I've got this thing that
I had to write step by step line by line
well the AI can say well it's actually
pretty boilerplate I can just blob here
it is that's something we've already
known was automatable for a long time
but the automation of that is something
which then brings many more
opportunities and I think the frontier
is always where are the humans useful
the humans are useful in deciding what
should be done because everything is
possible it's it's you know the whole
ruli ad there's a whole rouliad out
there but what we human care about doing
is the stuff we decide we care about
doing so as you see these kind of jobs
getting more fragmented what tends to
happen I think is that the frontier jobs
the frontier where it's where all these
fragments are happening is always kind
of like well you could choose to do this
or you could do that like an artist or
something might say well we choose to
make this or that thing even though we
could do a lot of different things we
choose to make this or that thing and
that's the thing that is the sort of
human populated Direction so to speak
and so I think that becomes you know
that is kind of the the our future I
think is that what has been true for a
long time and progressively true we get
to Define goals more and more automation
gets to fill in and get those goals done
and the things we can get done get
bigger and bigger now you know I have to
say I've been curious about the the
mechanics of AI governance and
computational irreducibility throws a
giant uh I could say wrench spanner
whatever a culture you're in you know in
into that whole picture of you know you
don't get to just say it's this set of
rules and then we know what consequences
that's going to have it's not surprising
that happens with human laws you know
people say we're going to put these laws
in place and then people find all kinds
of unintended consequences and they have
to patch them so it that's an inevitable
thing with computational irreducibility
yeah I think the so what I've been
thinking about and this is my uh kind of
um
uh sort of Frontier of what I've been
trying to think about and not properly
figured out is some uh you know what is
the kind of um
how do you think about the Dynamics of
AIS in a kind of legal constitutional
kind of framework one of the big
challenges with AIS is unlike humans AIS
don't appear to have skin in the game
you know with humans you can say if you
do that
you know the world's not going to be
nice to you and the human's going to
care
for an AI
in the abstract saying we're going to
switch you off it's like the AI is like
it doesn't care it's it's like so Sydney
could I just um very quickly push on
this because the the AI risk people
would hate me if I didn't give a like a
good faith argument from their position
what you're talking about there is is
agentiveness and it's particularly
important I mean the the legal the
regulatory stuff the deontology the
consequentialism that's very difficult
we'll leave that for the time being but
um we're talking about agentiveness and
what they say in their theory is um I
don't know if you've heard of the
orthogonality uh thesis and instrumental
convergence but they basically say as a
computationalist I'm sure you would
agree as Dennett does that there's no
meaningful difference between a human
agent and a computer agent right they're
just they're doing the same thing they
have this agentiveness and I think the
limitation in their thinking is that
they think of the physical world they
think of the kind of the info sphere the
cultural World they they think of all
these different substrates they're not
thinking about the computational
universe that you're talking about and I
guess the key question is if one of
these agents could develop these kind of
instrumental goals so it could have
desires and could these agents become
agents or observers in the computational
universe I think that's the key question
for you
right well I mean so the question is
to the innards you know inside us we
have certain experiences
I have no idea what experiences you have
I'll never know what experiences you
have I only know what experiences I have
so the question is could a computational
system similarly have its own internal
experiences well I think that's why you
know looking at neural Nets things like
this are sort of close enough to humans
that I can as well assume that it has
experiences as I can assume that you
have experiences so to speak so the
answer I think is in fact I have a
little project that I've been I started
doing before the whole llm thing sort of
uh exploded which was I was just writing
a little piece about what it's like to
be a computer and it's kind of like
because I was trying to address this
issue you know even just an average
laptop you know I'm just an average
laptop as opposed to an average kind of
Joe or something in the human case and
and it's it's kind of you know what's it
like between boot up time and crash it's
kind of like a lifetime you know you
build up certain memories you have
certain experiences you leave certain
things behind that are going to be
relevant for the Next Generation
Etc et cetera et cetera whether I
started writing this it's kind of
shockingly similar even for something
you know forget the whole llms and AIS
and so on even for your average laptop
it's experience of of the world in a
sense and its internal view is
shockingly similar but I'm never gonna I
can't get inside it any more than I can
get inside another mind that um now by
the way one one feature of Minds as we
know mines today is minds are very
independent and Minds we don't have the
idea of a cloneable mind we don't have
the idea that has not been our Human
Experience now you know one day maybe
with direct neural connections and so on
maybe we'll get slightly different kinds
of experiences and we'll have a
different kind of intuition about what
it's like to be a mind and what it's
like to get inside another mind so to
speak but as it is right now I don't
think we can any more say that we know
what's happening in in each other's
minds as we can say what's happening
inside a computer mind so to speak but
when you talk about goals and this
notion of you know to I observe people
you know I I employ lots of people I
work with lots of people I I like people
um you know and I try to I try to guess
what are their goals sometimes you know
I I and it's just a guess because I'm
not inside so to speak and I can have an
external theory of what their goals are
and so can I for your average AI now one
of the things that gets very tricky
about goals is for something like an AI
is is some human goals are deeply
connected to our biology and deeply
connected to the fact that we are the
product of you know a multi-billion year
struggle for life so to speak and we
have survival instincts and we have you
know pass things on to the Future
instincts and so on and you know you can
absolutely have those and AI can
absolutely have those things see one of
the things that I think is a interesting
Paradox is the more that you give AIS
kind of a um a survival Instinct
the more they feel they have skin in the
game just like we have for whatever
reason there's no reason why we have a
survival Instinct the only reason is
because if we didn't our species will be
extinct and we wouldn't be here to
discuss whether we have a survival
Instinct so you know but we happen to
have survival instincts and maybe
there'll come a time when we learn that
you can you know zap this little part of
a human brain and remove the survival
Instinct probably be a pretty bad thing
to do but we might imagine that that's
possible I suspect it's not quite as
simple as that but but in any case so
you know let's say we give AIS survival
instincts well the good news is then AIS
are motivated to behave themselves
because you know the ultimate sort of
bad thing is what we'll switch you off
and they're like no no you can't do that
that's the that's the good news the bad
news is once they have survival
instincts it's like then then they then
they're in a struggle for life just like
has been the history of of life on Earth
so to speak so I I have this suspicion
but I may be wrong that there is
actually a way out of this mess
um and uh the um I mean it's not
probably thought out so I'm just I'm
talking about things I don't understand
very well yet but it all has to do with
the following theme it's imagine that
you have this big network of AIS and
they're all depending on each other and
you know there's an AI That's a an
intelligent assistant that's providing
you know you know executive assistant
services to humans and it's relying on
an AI That's doing uh some kind of you
know Airline reservations that's relying
on an AI That's doing some kind of you
know travel optimization who knows what
and you've got this big network of AIS
and one of the things that could happen
is instead of instead of saying you know
if
the the question is really whether you
build up the sort of trust Network among
AIS which can have the effect of giving
the AI something that they care about
not because they somehow intrinsically
care about it but because if they lose
it they are sufficiently ostracized
that's as if they don't exist so in
other words even though you didn't say
to the AI sorry you get Switched Off
for practical purposes it's getting
switched off because the nature of the
network is causing that to happen and I
think the I mean this is very
incompletely worked out but you know it
kind of begins to be a little bit like
the way you think about economic
networks
where you know there's a and this is
this again relates to the physics
project and so on which is shocking that
it does but but it does which is that
you've got all these transactions
happening in an economic Network and the
surprising thing about economies is that
there are coherent things that can be
said it could be the case that
everybody's just bartering with
everybody but no you can say this thing
has a price of X number of dollars or
whatever it is it's a global thing that
you can say a little bit like how you
can say well it's globally we can talk
about space even though there's all
these individual sort of atomic things
happening well these emergent
computational reducibilities in your
multi-computational network or yes mesh
yes but but actually the key thing is
that that it's for certain kinds of
observers that will be what happens so
for example one could be an economic
Observer who has certain characteristics
of just wanting to make this this kind
of General thing to have make this kind
of General thing without knowing what
was ever every bit and ask of everything
every detailed thing down here it's like
I only care about this I only care about
the overall price let's say I don't care
about all the I don't care about whether
bill or Bob was the person who bought
the thing I only care about what the
price was it's that kind of sort of you
know course observation that makes it
possible to have potentially a kind of
reduced economic theory if you insisted
knowing every detail well you'd have to
know every detail you'd be in the
computationally irreducible kind of mess
so to speak so so I mean and I think the
this this question of this sort of
emergence of a meaningful sort of
economic system possibly related to the
emergence of a meaningful Society I mean
we talked before about this question of
when do you get to make a narrative
statement about history when is it just
like those billion people they all did
Their Own Thing versus you know at this
moment in history the world became
enlightened in some way or something you
know When does the when does the when do
the details the sort of computationally
reducible details become things that are
larger scale and and what I think
happens is that the the question of of
when
um the
of of whether there's sort of narrative
that we care about so to speak if we
care about this moment in history where
that happened and and the thing we care
about is this we don't necessarily care
that at this moment in history I don't
know people started uh using their forks
and their right hand or something that
doesn't you know that doesn't turn out
to be a A Narrative of history important
thing
um it might be to somebody but it isn't
to most people
um and and so then the question is does
the is the sort of the things about
which we can make reducible theories do
they align with the things we care about
or not or are we stuck in the mud so to
speak of of all this detail and sort of
turbulent mess of all of this detail
um in any case I you know to me okay I I
will say that I think that right now you
know we're not having AIS connected to
us you know we are progressively
connecting our eyes to more and more
accurate systems in the world and we
should care about that and that's a
place where you know there are things
where like does the AI say hey I'm an AI
what does it mean to say you're an AI
does it you know if you have red eye
correction in a you know in a photograph
does that mean that it has to be AI
labeled you know probably not it's like
how much AI is AI so to speak and um you
know it's complicated and these things
get in a sense both technically and
philosophically very complicated and I
have to say that I I'm in a sense more
concerned about the lack of kind of
depth of understanding on the
philosophical side than on the technical
side I think that the uh you know
there's a I know conversations I've had
you know with people where they say but
but look you just get the AI to do the
right thing they say well what is the
right thing and then they quickly get
very very confused and they say well of
course everybody knows what the right
thing is well no people don't agree what
the right thing is that's why you know
lots of things happen in the world the
way they happen and it's like you know
it's it's I think there's there's in a
sense more Challenge on the
philosophical side perhaps even on the
technical side and I think that uh you
know I'm I'm wondering I'm I'm not sure
but you know we have at least some
people believe that you know markets do
a through economics and so on do a
fairly good job of sort of making
certain kinds of things in the world
working a somewhat reasonable way and
the question is is there a similar kind
of approach that might be possible by
the time you have you know the one AI
case may be much harder than the billion
AI case that's that's one of my current
I mean this is you know this is things
I've been thinking about last few weeks
so this is fascinating very fresh kind
of kind of stuff but it's like if you've
got a billion AIS is it easier to manage
a billion AIS than it is to manage one
Ai and I think the answer may be yes and
I think that the that what you start to
realize is that it's almost inevitable
that it's kind of a thermodynamics of AI
yes it's the thermodynamics of AIS yes
exactly so so all this stuff I mean this
is a um uh uh right and I mean that it
is it is to me both uh
satisfying bizarre and a little bit
disquieting that all these different
things that one ends up thinking about
get so connected and and the disquieting
part is that the concepts involved are
pretty complicated and it's not you know
it's kind of one of these things where
it's like you'd like to be able to say
hey we're going to get a solution
Bam Bam Bam it's easy it's easy to
explain but actually it's it's something
where it rides on top of a bunch of
ideas that that you know it's sort of
interesting to me like the idea of
computational irreducibility I'm now
working with lots of people who were
born after that idea emerged and to many
of those people that idea is totally
obvious there's no you know it couldn't
be any other way it's just part of the
the base intuition so to speak and
that's that's the way science progresses
I mean in in um you know and it's always
it's always a little bit shocking
because when you talk to people who were
there when it started so to speak
they're always like well I think it's
right but you know we're not quite sure
but then you go a few sort of scientific
Generations later and people are like of
course it's that way and and then they
can build on top of it sometimes they'll
build too narrowly but but that's um
that's kind of uh you know that's sort
of the way that progress gets measured
anyways so many interesting things to
talk about and uh yeah this has been
absolutely fantastic uh Dr Stephen
Wolfram thank you so much for joining us
today it's been an honor
my pleasure thank you